ich bin schon eine Quereinsteigerin und
dann mache ich auch noch alles anders
als es die Leichtathleten jetzt zu
machen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
herzlich
österreichischen Bundesheers heute zu
Gast vorgefreiter Julia herzlich
willkommen liebe Julia du bist
Leichtathletin was früher mal
Fußballerin und bist wahnsinnig
erfolgreich in deiner Sport hat
offensichtlich hast du die perfekten
Anlagen zum Laufen ist das so es scheint
so ja es hat sich relativ spät
herausgestellt dass ich gut laufen kann
aber jetzt unser erfolgreicher du bist
doof Meisterschaft Finalistin dreifach
österreichische Rekordhalter Nummer 5000
10.000 und dem Halbmarathon und bis vor
kurzem 17 fache Staatsmeisterin und ich
glaube du hast in Wälder noch einen
Wettkampf ich glaube die
österreichischen Meisterschaften das
heißt du bist erst seit kurzem
Leichtathletin und schon ist so
erfolgreich was macht denn dein
Erfolgsrezept aus
ich denke es ist mein Ehrgeiz gepaart
wahrscheinlich doch mit Talent und viel
Arbeit du warst du bis 2016 Fußballerin
hast damit einen Sport betrieben der
damals im Frauenbereich noch nicht auf
dem professionalisierungsniveau war von
den Rahmenbedingungen her und bis dann
so Leichtathletik gewechselt warum genau
ich war lange Zeit Fußballerin ich habe
mit sieben oder acht Jahren begonnen
meine Heimatgemeinde Bad fischerbrunn
und
habe dann aufgrund äh ja ähm ich habe
studiert war fußballtrainerin und das
war alles relativ viel ich habe den
Sprung in den Nationalmannschaft nie
geschafft und aus Zeitgründen habe ich
das mal beseitigt und durch Spaß beim
Wiener Neid run mitgelaufen und von
allen Seiten habe ich gehört Julia das
ist richtig gut was du machst fangen
professionelles zu machen
Fußballtraining irgendwie gezielt
auszudrehen gemacht dass du lange
Tempel machst oder lange aus der
Einheiten machst damit du da diese 5000
so schnell läuft beim eigentlich nicht
ich meine sicher laufen macht mich hat
mir viel Spaß gemacht immer schon aber
so gezielt trainiert habe ich nicht ich
war vielleicht ein oder zweimal in der
Woche so ja 20 30 Minuten Joggen
zusätzlich zum Fußballtraining aber mehr
war es nicht du warst dann auf Anhieb
Staatsmeisterin über die 5000 was hast
du dir da gedacht ist das passiert ist
ja das war ein cooles Rennen
ich bin mit der Kathi Grandl Runde für
Hunde haben uns abgewechselt vorne und
wir hatten damals den selben Trainer das
war auch irrsinnig witzig davor dann so
dass er und sagt ja ihr Laufzeit und
dann schaut was rauskommt und das waren
meine zweiten Staatsmeisterschaften nach
Kos wo ich ich glaube Vierter geworden
bin oder so und genau und dann über die
5000 sind wir in die letzte Runde rein
und irgendwie habe ich immer noch in mir
so diesen diesen Sprint dieses Bild
Fähigkeiten vom Fußball die man da ja
doch hat und bin auf den letzten 150
Metern vor und es war aber doch knapp es
war wirklich knapp Außenstehende haben
es gar nicht wirklich mitbekommen wir
haben dann auch aufs Foto Finish auf das
Ziel Foto warten müssen und ich habe
aber bin aber schon Hände nach oben wenn
ich ins Ziel durch und alle haben sich
so gedacht wahrscheinlich was macht die
da es ist eigentlich noch nicht wirklich
fix wäre jetzt gewonnen hat und ich habe
es aber irgendwie gespürt und es war
halt dann noch so also richtig richtig
cool das ist so das ist ein Gefühl dass
du jetzt da die letzten Metern noch
aufgeholt hast und dann springt wirklich
erfolgreich gewesen ist
wie passiert dann oder was passiert dann
wenn man da jetzt aus dem Stand heraus
gleich einmal Staatsmeister wird und
damit die beste ist in einer neuen
Disziplin was sagen die Leute was
passiert im Umfeld was denkt man sich
selbst ja es war glaube ich so in der
Leichtathletik Szene also wer ist das
kennt man nicht und bei mir was dann
eigentlich so der Anstoß dass ich sage
okay das ist richtig cool ich glaube da
ist wirklich und ich bin extrem
ehrgeizig und wenn ich dann merke
irgendwas macht mir Spaß und ich bin
jetzt schon mal gut dann habe ich
gedacht ja okay alles oder nichts und
bin dann eigentlich 18 19 das hat sich
dann weiterentwickelt und
insgeheim habe ich mir schon Ende 2017
gedacht ich möchte das eigentlich
professionell machen und habe halt dann
wirklich schon gekauft ja wie kann man
in Österreich professionell Sport
betreiben und da war schon mein
Hintergedanke das Bundesheer weil die
damals schon klar ich habe das Potenzial
ich kann da wirklich Großes erreichen
nach diesem Lauf weil einfach gesehen
hast da ist noch so viel mit drin ja es
klingt jetzt irgendwie blöd oder
vielleicht überheblich aber ich habe es
mir einfach damals schon gedacht also
ich habe große Ziele die die schon
eigentlich lange im Kopf sind ich denke
das ist aber auch sowas was mich dann
antreibt auch so weit und wie schwer es
weg ist dass du desto mehr möchtest das
angesprochen du bist jetzt seit 2020
beim Bundesheer aber wie weit weg war
das damals das ist dein erster
Staatsmeister die du gemacht hast und
nicht gesagt so da Schatzi ich möchte
zum her es gibt ja nur begrenzte Plätze
auch in der leichtathletiker wie weit
weg war das dass du das schaffst es war
weit weg
ich weiß es Mehrheit von von dem Siegen
nicht mehr aber es war auch keine
besonders schnelle Zeit ich denke es war
irgendwas um die 17 Minuten und wenn man
dann sagt ja ich möchte es mit 17
Minuten da ins Bundesheer das ich war
noch nicht mal im Nationalteam das war
ein zweites Rennen also niemand also ich
habe es auch nicht laut ausgesprochen
dass ich das professionell machen möchte
und und welche Ziele ich habe weil er
hat mich jeder für dumm abgestempelt und
ja dann habe ich einfach so weiter
trainiert und meinen meinen Weg einfach
weitergemacht und
2019 hat sich dann herauskristallisiert
das ist in die Richtung gehen könnte
der war dann meine
Zeit über 5000 schon 16 Minuten und ich
wurde auch ein Beruf ins nationalleben
bin die Thymian gelaufen rechter
erfolgreich oder der dritte über die
5000 Meter hinter also hinter der
Salpeter die ja jetzt in der
Leichtathletik ein unfassbares Jahr
gehabt hat und da war dann der Schritt
wo ich gesagt habe okay ich bewerbe mich
und ich möchte das machen
wieso hast du auch gemerkt dass du
Rückhalt gekommen ist dass der Szene
oder vielleicht auch Gegenwind einer
einer späteren einen eine
Quereinsteigerin oder sozusagen
so und so muss ich sagen
[Musik]
ich bin von Anfang an so meinen Weg
gegangen ich bin schon eine
Quereinsteigerin und dann mache ich auch
noch alles anders also es ist die
leichte Läden jetzt zu machen ich bin
auch was das trainingsbezogene betrifft
ich bin nicht verviel Fahrrad ich schaue
bin jetzt so ein untypischer Typ einfach
vom ausschauen auch ich bin extrem
muskulös und ich habe ihn dann zum
Verband hin und habe gesagt ich bewerbe
mich und die haben eigentlich
aufgrund meiner Leistungen die einfach
so waren und so gut waren wie sie waren
gesagt ja passt wir machen das wir
unterstützen dich und das ist dann
einfach so gekommen und ich bin jetzt
nicht dankbar dass sie mich das
unterstützt haben auch 2020 wo man ja
aufgrund von einer schwankenden
Leistungsbreite eigentlich nicht ganz so
gut war haben sie doch gesagt wir wir
glauben an dich und ja was kann ich
jetzt sagen ich bin jetzt nach zwei
Jahren Profi Leistungssport dreifacher
österreichische Rekord halt drin das
hätte ich ohne Unterstützung vom vom
Verband und vom Bundesheer halt nie
geschafft und vor allem über Distanzen
die man wie du gesagt hast jetzt von
deinem Typ her oder auch von deiner
ehemaligen Sportart her nicht so gleich
auf Anhieb denken würde nämlich eben die
5000 die 10.000 und den Halbmarathon mal
wieder eher Glauben 400 800 würden eher
passen dort ist vor kurzem auch noch die
Cross Meisterschaften wie es ist dir da
gegangen genau da ist es mir auch sehr
gut gegangen jetzt bin ich mittlerweile
18-fache Staatsmeisterin war ein cooles
Rennen war ein Vorarlberg ist nichts
schwerer Kurs war sehr sehr lässig und
ja ich bin jetzt nicht mehr so breit
gefächert aufgestellt aber ich habe auch
früher die 800 bin ich auch gelaufen zu
Beginn in den ersten zwei Jahren und es
hat sich dann aber herausgestellt dass
dann doch das Talent auf den längeren
Distanzen liegt was eigentlich
widersprüchlich ist zum Fußball wieder
sagst es ist witzig und es macht mir
aber jetzt nicht viel Spaß auf die
längeren Distanzen eigentlich also so
800 Meter oder nur die eine Stadionrunde
die 400 das wäre das wäre nichts für
mich zu kurz zu langweilig für Julia
Mayer jetzt auch noch im Cross auch noch
zusätzliche Staatsmeister ist jetzt
18-fache staatsmeisterinnen wenigen
Jahren man hat so das Gefühl du liebst
die Herausforderungen ja auf jeden Fall
also ich habe einige Ziele die in meinem
Kopf waren habe ich jetzt schon abgehakt
kann ich sagen ja passt ist gut gegangen
aber es sind noch einige einige größere
noch dadurch also Ziele die ich
unbedingt erreichen möchte auch solche
wo ich eben wie gesagt jetzt
auch die ich nicht laut aussprechen wo
ich dann wahrscheinlich auch wieder
belächelt werde aber ja die
Herausforderungen machen saß deswegen
bist du im Schwarzwald damit du sie
aussprichst und wie wir uns dann mit Dir
gemeinsam freuen wenn du sie auch
erfüllen ähm wirst jetzt hast du bei
deinen wichtigen Wettkämpfen so gut wie
immer deine beste Zeiten verbessert und
ist immer steil nach oben gegangen ist
immer schneller geworden glaubst du dass
das so weitergehen wird oder wirst du
irgendwann einmal um die hundertste
aufhalten Distanz zu kämpfen müssen ich
denke das ist auch kommen wird man
kämpft ihr jetzt also in meinem Fall
jetzt auch um Minuten es ist immer quasi
kommt gegen die gegen die Zeit
bei mir ist es so ich mache es im
Training auch schon so es ist jedes
Training das wichtig ist das muss bei
mir dann besser sein als das andere ich
stelle mich darauf schon im Training
mental darauf ein dass es halt ja ein
immer ein Kampf ist um um gegen die Zeit
und von dem her ja es wird irgendwann
sicherlich nicht so einfach sein aber
derzeit ist es noch einfach in Malaga
bist du dieses Jahr einen neuen
österreichischen Rekord im halbmatum
gelaufen war das ein Ziel von dir dass
du nicht ausgesprochen hast dass du dann
aber geschafft hast ja ich bin meine
abschlusstrainingseinheit war nicht gut
und ich habe dann auf die
österreichische Bestenliste geschaut was
muss ich schlafen
und habe gesehen okay das kann sich
ausgehen und in Malaga selbst dann doch
recht nervös und Verhalten am Start weil
es das erste Rennen der Saison war wo
man nie weiß wie es die Form jetzt man
braucht ein paar Rennen um in Form zu
kommen bin es dann defensiv gelaufen und
habe dann den letzten Kilometer auf die
Uhr gescheiter gesehen es geht sich aus
richtig cool den letzten Kilometer
gesprengt das zu sagen aber glaubst du
wenn du vorher nicht auf die Liste
geschaut hättest dass du das auch
hinbekommen hättest Dich ich habe in
meinem Fall ähnliches Erlebnis gehabt
bei einer Kurzform Wettkampf 2008 da
habe ich einmal warum auch immer auf die
weltrekordlisten geschaut und dann haben
wir 50 Brust das muss doch gehen das
schaffe ich doch und bin dann am
nächsten Tag weil ich eben die Zeit
wusste ich schaffen muss genau diese
Zeit danach geschwommen und habe den
Weltrekord geschafft glaubst du dass
wenn du nicht auf die Liste geschaut
hättest und nicht gewusst hätte das
jetzt aus dem Stand was du laufen
müsstest dass das automatisch passiert
wäre oder hast du dieses konkrete Ziel
gebraucht was du laufen musst
ich denke ich hätte wer hätte es auch so
geschafft man man weiß ja laufen ist ja
Bereich also man berechnet das alles man
weiß ganz genau eigentlich was man was
man kann und wenn dann die Verfassung
die Beine wenn die passen dann läuft man
das auch und das Abschlusstraining war
so dass man eigentlich ich konnte mir
ausrechnen dass kann ich laufen wenn es
gut geht also ich habe mir eigentlich
vorgenommen ich lauf zwischen 70 und 72
Minuten irgendwas und schöner wäre
natürlich gewesen wenn es noch schneller
gewesen wäre aber ich hoffe das kommt
noch
irgendwo irgendwann und dann geht's
plötzlich und plötzlich ist alles
möglich was vorher nicht möglich war du
hast dich ja damals für die halt immer
davon Weltmeisterschaft qualifiziert
jetzt nicht gegeben wie schade findest
du das dass du da noch nicht auch auf
diesem Niveau dabei sein konntest extrem
schade das wäre meine erste Weltmeister
Weltmeisterschaft gewesen ich habe mich
richtig gefreut
dann Weltmeisterschaft seine Limit das
läuft man nicht alle Tage und
es hat nicht sein sollen vielleicht
kommt's noch und ich habe mich aber
wieder Europameisterschaft qualifiziert
das war genauso schön genau das was da
noch gleich im Finale was du zufrieden
mit deiner Leistung
ja es war leider so dass vor mir eine
Athletin gestürzt ist und das war halt
bei mir das war knapp um Kilometer drei
oder extrem hoch dann schon war
für mich das Limit ich glaube es sind da
um die 37 wo man Kilometer so gerade
gelaufen dass ich ist für mich über die
10.000 schauen das absolute Maximum und
dann bin ich in die vordere Brauerei
gelaufen und quasi gestanden musste das
Loch dann zulaufen und dann ist halt
leider Gottes
was ich eigentlich gedacht hätte und
deswegen so lala zufrieden aber ich bin
das Loch zugelaufen hatte dann zwei drei
Kilometer wo ich mir extrem schwer dann
habe bin aber irrsinnig stolz dass ich
da dann noch weiter gelaufen bin und
hinten raus sind eigentlich noch wieder
ansehnliche Rundenzeiten gelaufen bin
das heißt auch deine Elemente die dann
doch nicht so kalkulieren weil das kann
natürlich nicht berechnen was ist wenn
jemand zu Sturz kommt und man kurz
blockiert wird oder eben ein bisschen
ans Limit laufen muss um das Loch
zuzulaufen wie gehst du damit um wie
bereitest du dich auf sowas vor blendest
das komplett aus und wenn sie eintritt
dann findest du deine Lösung oder hast
du das im mentalen ähm Schließfach
irgendwo abgesperrt und rufst dann ab
wenn du es Brauchst ich bin jetzt
eigentlich komplett aus meine Beine
erfahre meine bahnrinnen Erfahrung ist
jetzt nicht sonderlich groß kann man
wahrscheinlich so an ja
vielleicht eher an beiden Händen
abzählen dementsprechend ich war noch
nie in einem Sturz verwickelt kann ich
jetzt nicht wirklich sagen wie gehe ich
da immer mit um und ich im Vorhinein
haben wir auch nicht damit gerechnet
dass man sagt bei den 10.000 Meter
passiert ein Sturz ist eher selten
deswegen ja ausgeblendet währenddessen
habe ich dann versucht
im ersten Moment habe ich gedacht ja
scheiße super hat es auf jeden Fall
Europameisterschaft auf und das direkt
vor mir und dann habe ich einfach ja
mental versucht alles rauszuholen das
Publikum das war das war hilfreich die
haben mich dann einfach wieder quasi
getragen und ja was denkst du wenn
möglich gewesen ist natürlich immer blöd
dass er die wahre und was wäre wenn
möglich gewesen wenn es diesen Sturz
nicht gegeben hätte wenn du deinen Plan
von A bis Z komplett durchgezogen
hättest dann
wäre vielleicht zwei drei Platzierungen
besser möglich gewesen definitiv meine
beste Zeit hätte ich eingestellt und das
ist natürlich schade
aber es ist wie es ist und ich bin auch
jetzt mit der Platzierung mit der Zeit
mit der Teilnahme zufrieden und du hast
natürlich noch einiges vor eine
Weltmeisterschaft in sich auch noch
erfolgen auch wenn die eine noch nicht
geklappt hat du
hast natürlich ein großes Ziel das auch
in Richtung Paris gehen soll wie kommst
du so eine Olympischen Spielen nach
Paris genau ich möchte mich über die
Marathon Distanz für Paris qualifizieren
mittlerweile gibt es da ja mehrere
Möglichkeiten es wurde ja viel
umgemodelt was die Qualifikation
Limits betrifft und man kann sich direkt
qualifizieren mit einer Zeit von 28 30
das ist schon sehr sehr schnell aber
schwebt mir so in meinen in meinen
Zielen eigentlich vor dass ich das
laufen möchte sonst über das Ranking
und es gibt sogar eine dritte
Möglichkeit im Marathon dass das Land
sagen kann wir nehmen einen Athleten mit
Männer oder Frauen und ja sprich drei
Möglichkeiten um mich zu qualifizieren
und mein Training ist so ausgerichtet
dass es aber über die über die Zeit
funktioniert und warum würdest du das
auf die Marathon-Distanz gehen wollen
und nicht auf die anderen auf die Fünfer
die Zähne und dann
wir haben festgestellt dass ich auf der
längeren Distanz dann doch im Vergleich
zur Weltspitze besser bin als über die 5
und 10.000 da ist es schon irrsinnig
schnell da fehlt mir eventuell die Zeit
die ich Fußball gespielt habe
man muss dann doch gewisse Fertigkeiten
mitbringen die ich noch nicht habe
derzeit oder vielleicht nie haben wird
über die halt machen und Distanz und
Marathon und Distanz ist das dann so
dass sich das viele Training an der
Schwelle voranbringt das ist bei mir so
ich weiß ich muss irrsinnig viel
trainieren
um eventuell die verlorenen Jahre die
ich nicht gelaufen bin aufzuholen wenn
man das so sagen kann also ich bin quasi
so ein Arbeitstier stärt mich nicht ich
trainiere sie nicht gerne und hoffe dass
ich durch das viele Training dann da
aufschließen kann und das heißt das Ziel
über die Zeit dich zu qualifizieren dass
erfüllst du dir indem du viel an der
Stelle läufst und damit aufhören kannst
was Du aus den Jahren davor nicht hast
jetzt ist es so das war angesprochen
dass deine Bahn Erfahrung noch sehr
begrenzt ist aber ich nehme auch an auch
deine Marathon Erfahrung ist noch sehr
begrenzt das haben deine Konkurrentinnen
wahrscheinlich dann dir voraus oder
hilft es Dir dass Du fast schon
unbekümmert in dieser Rennen gehen
kannst weil du eben noch nicht vor
belastet bist durch
zigfache Erfahrungen negativ oder
positiv davor ja voll ich finde es
eigentlich gut dass ich teilweise so aus
der andere Rolle an den Start gehen kann
niemand beachtet mich niemand
interessiert sich für mich mittlerweile
ein bisschen anders aber es ist dann
doch angenehm man kann sich komplett auf
sich selber konzentrieren und läuft
einfach macht sich nicht zu viele
Gedanken das ist extrem positiv
andererseits muss ich sagen so in den
letzten zwei Jahren ist dann die
Erfahrung die man macht extrem wichtig
die Erfahrung die man im Training
sammelt weil du weißt erstens worauf
sprichst du im Training an wie
gestaltest du das eigentlich so genau
und dann natürlich im Rennen die
Rennerfahrung ist auch extrem wichtig
also da bin ich jetzt schon dann doch
froh dass ich ein paar Rennen einfach
gemacht habe um zu sehen ja wie startet
man einen Rennen wieder als ich meinen
10000 Meter Lauf ein wiederholt man sich
halt machen dann ein das wäre Marathon
wird natürlich wie du sagst extrem
spannend
[Musik]
gibt es noch nicht so viele Leute die
ich über die 42 km absolviert habe im
Grunde genommen waren zwei der erste ist
recht gut gegangen der zweite nicht ganz
so gut und im Training läuft man dann
auch mittlerweile sind meine Tempo Läufe
auch relativ lang da kommt man dann
schon langsam so rein in das Gefühl der
marathanistan sehr wie viel glaubst du
noch brauchen bist du in Paris einen
Start gehst
gute Frage ich hoffe es ist definitiv
nur einer wo ich extrem schnell sein
werde und ja um dann in Paris
bestmöglich vorzubereiten vorbereitet zu
stehen während es dann doch noch
zwei oder drei sein wenn du sagst du
hast noch ganz viele unausgesprochene
Ziele jetzt ist so dass man ja im
Marathon nicht unbedingt nur abhängig
ist von den Großereignissen sondern es
gibt deshalb Prestige trächtigte
Marathons unabhängig des ähm
organisierten strukturierten Laufsport
ist also in in bestimmten Städten gibt
es irgendeinen Wunsch Marathon den
unbedingt einmal laufen möchtest oder
vielleicht ganze Fahne dabei sein
möchtest ja also
besten oder New York Essen schon cool ja
das sind schon coole live verfallen
Posten extrem hügelig mag ich extrem
gern
wäre schon ein Ziel von mir dort gut zu
laufen ja du hast 16 Jahre Fußball
gespielt und hast dann die Sportart
gewechselt als der Fußballplatz ein
bisschen im Aufwind war wie hast du die
Entwicklung des Frauenfußballs in den
letzten Jahren so mit verfolgt
extrem cool zu sehen dass es ähm dann
ich weg war eigentlich weggegangen ist
dementsprechend ja ich verfolgt das
immer noch sehr es sind noch einige
meiner Freundinnen da mit dabei mit
denen ich auch in der Mannschaft
gespielt habe und ich finde es irrsinnig
cool dass das jetzt einfach auch als
professionelle Sportart angesehen wird
und jetzt nicht so modern geredet wird
ja wir sind Frauen und warum ist das
jetzt irgendwie anders zu betrachten ich
finde das total sinnlos eigentlich
ja coole Sache aber ist da vielleicht
auch ein bisschen weinendes Auge dass du
diesen Schub finde ich nicht miterlebt
hast und vielleicht eine Stunde
geschafft hättest deine Anlagen dazu die
hast ja offensichtlicher auch und deine
Fähigkeiten also denkst du dir darauf
war da hätte ich jetzt weiter WM Quali
oder bei der EM dabei sein können oder
eher nicht realistisch ich bin lange
nicht so gut wie die Mädels die da
auflaufen und von dem her bin ich froh
dass ich als zuschauen kann wie
erfolgreich sie sind und das macht mir
extrem viel Spaß was ich aber sagen muss
mittlerweile geht mir der Fußball ein
bisschen ab also jetzt so die letzten
paar Wochen warum auch immer vielleicht
durch das erfolgreiche Spielen der
Mädels denke ich mal so es geht mal
schon es geht man schon ab ja kannst du
das Anbauen in dein Training oder ist es
einfach zu gefährlich es ist erstens
viel zu gefährlich und zweitens ganz
andere Bewegungsablauf ich habe das ich
bin ja Lehrerin karenzierte und wie ich
dann so 2018/19 schon viel gelaufen bin
habe ich ab und an mit dem Burschen und
auch mit den Mädels Sportunterricht
mitgespielt und da merkt man dann aber
dass das ganz andere Bewegungsabläufe
sind man ist viel langsamer unbeweglich
also das lässt sich nicht mehr vereinbar
ja das Kapitel das ist zu aber den einen
Traum von Olympia den hätte ich
natürlich im Fußball nicht erfüllen
können in der Leichtathletik geht dass
er sich niemand anders da die Freude
überwiegt oder ja auf jeden Fall also
ich bin auch mit der Entwicklung die ich
jetzt durch deshalb in den wenigen
Jahren extrem happy also ich bin
eigentlich recht froh dass ich den
Schritt gewagt habe und mir jetzt noch
den traumolympia fühlen kann und die
anderen
richtig coolen Rekorde die ich jetzt
habe genießen kann und Olympia genießen
und und Traum erfüllen das ist ja noch
einige Male können vor allem im Marathon
gibt es ja fast kein Alterslimit für
Topleistungen wie viel Olympische Spiele
möchtest du denn noch erleben nach Paris
die du dann hoffentlich erleben wirst
definitiv 24 und ja danach ich glaube es
sind dann ist das dann Los Angeles
definitiv noch so
im Bereich des wirklich
32 wäre dann darauf aber ich bin mir
sicher dass wenn du dann auch im Marat
erfolgreich bist dass du da nicht so
schnell aufhören wirst ich habe noch ein
paar Fragen an dich an meinem Sport
begeistert mich am meisten
die ständige
Fortschritt
extrem spannend zu sehen wie sich das in
den Jahren weiterentwickelt hat vor
allem bei mir jetzt sind sie kurze Zeit
extrem cool
wenn ich nicht Sportlerin wäre dann wäre
ich wahrscheinlich Lehrerin oder bin ich
Lehrerin richtig warum ja Herzblut ist
da dabei ich arbeite irrsinnig gern mit
Kindern und wahrscheinlich auch ein
bisschen familiär bedingt ich habe Opa
Oma Tante Onkel Cousine die sind alle
Lehrer und Lehrerinnen und ich habe das
schon in der Volksschule so als
Traumberuf gesehen also Familie
vorbelastet welche Art von Lehrerin bist
Du genau Mittelschule Sport und Deutsch
sehr gut meine stärkste Eigenschaft ist
meine Schwester Eigenschaft ist
ungeduldig und ja ich denke
das lässt sich aber gut vereinbar mit
der mit der stärkeren Eigenschaft es
gibt
blockiert dich das eher beim Training
beim Sport oder ist das sogar gut dass
Du geduldig bist
hätte ich keinen Trainer wäre es
wahrscheinlich
definitiv ein eines sehr schlechte
Eigenschaft aber er schafft es dann
immer mich irgendwie zu zügeln und mich
ja
einzubremsen man hört ja auch das auch
auf dem hohen Niveau wieder ohne Trainer
trainieren und wirklich nur ganz nach
nach Uhr oder nach Puls oder nach Gefühl
gehen
hältst du das für für gut möglich
schwierig wir sind sehr wir arbeiten
sehr wissenschaftlich sehr viel Mitleid
und anderen Werten ahm jedes Training
eigentlich wird da mit der
laktatgesteuert absolviert ich bin da
sehr sehr genau was das betrifft also
eher am anderen Spektrum Alter einfach
mal den zufallslauf machen am Tag und
schauen wie man sich fühlt ich träume
von Olympia 20 24 Paris mit Julia Meyer
wir wünschen Dir natürlich hier alles
Gute und viel Erfolg und danke dass du
bei uns warst sehr gerne
wir freuen uns noch auf ganz viele
Erfolge von ihr und danken Euch das hier
mit dabei was wir freuen uns auch wenn
ihr bald wieder dabei seid
[Applaus]